take a look at you know hey we took we
think was a pretty good shot at the
rules to begin with but look and see how
those rules played themselves out as
time went on and after about a year and
a half there were a couple instances
where I saw hey this isn't quite fair to
an athlete we needed to change that we
did so after a year and a half there was
a couple rules that we change the first
one there's kind of a funny story behind
this too was I don't remember when Nate
fought Connor I think the second time he
goes to the press conference after and
takes out a vape pen do you remember
that and someone asked him what he was
doing he said he was with CBD and at the
time the the rule was the in competition
period where CBD was prohibited lasted
until four hours after the conclusion of
the fight and he was clearly within that
time period so you saw two contacted me
and said hey you know technically nate
was in violation of this and i said hey
look this was not the intent of the rule
this is you know and they never
indicated that they were going to
sanction him but I made it clear explain
CBD for anybody that might not know what
we're talking about sure
so CBD is part of the you know the
marijuana plant but it's not
psychoactive part of it I know a lot of
our fighters anecdotally use it for
anti-inflammatory purposes I think I
mean have you ever used it or yes what
what other benefits is anxiety it's it's
great for people that are under stress
it it actually has a great response for
that I know a lot of people that use it
just for anxiety but anti-inflammation
is a big one that's the big one people
use it for Penny with arthritis love it
yeah again comparing to you know natural
plant derived product versus a synthetic
you know nonsteroidal antiinflammatory
advils tylenols carob toxic Anja yeah
probably common sense would would you
know in addition to science would say
that the T V DS may be a little bit
healthier for you nevertheless it was
prohibited in competition is it still no
so that was actually a rule change the
wada prohibited list which we followed
took it completely off the prohibited
list start at the main to 2018 so that's
great so does take CBD the entire time
they're training there's no it's
obviously there's no performance benefit
there's no psychoactive effect it just
reduces inflammation and it doesn't a
natural way way healthier and it was the
case before they could do it in training
was only prohibited in competition so
way in day and fight day now it's
completely been taken off the list and
it's okay to use it anytime that's
fantastic that's fantastic so it was
good so but we identified a problem with
with the rules in that when Nate
finished that that fight with Conor you
sada came to the post fight medical tent
set Nate we need to make a collection
from you and I don't know whether it was
blood or urine but they got a sample
from him he then went to the press
conference after and was on you know
took the CVD what I said is look you
can't punish him you have the sample
that shows what was in his system yes
CBD was prohibited in competition but
you have a sample to show whether or not
he was using it right it's clear that
you know he was using it after the fight
we just put those extra four hours in
there why with the thought of if a
fighter finishes a fight and somehow you
saw it is not able to get to him say
gets in the ambulance right away goes to
the hospital you increase that window
just in case they can't get them come to
find out as we started putting this
program together you saw it can always
get to that fighter after if they're
transported they can hop in the
ambulance with them it it wasn't an
issue where we needed those extra four
months so we changed that rule and now
basically the rule is the in competition
period ends with a collection
immediately after the fight or you know
you saw it has a reasonable amount of
time after the fight so the funny thing
is after we change this rule Nate and
Nick Diaz come to a fight they're
sitting called the Zuffa section you
know kind of Dana section right there
behind Dana's table so I go over to Nick
and Nate I say hey Nate man hey we
changed that rule
you know the whole CBD thing and
actually we kind of refer to it as as
the Nate Diaz rule and when the Diaz
brothers ratified I mean it's
pandemonium and chaos everybody's
yelling their name and I literally I'm
like I had the demon register with them
he didn't look at me he was looking
somewhere else so about a month later
Nate I see him and I think it was in
Vegas I'm in the kind of walk out tunnel
and here comes Nate so he sees me it
comes over me gives me a kind of the bro
hug what's up he's with Yancy Medeiros
and so Yancy and
I start talking and Nancy beyond being
just an unbelievably entertaining
fighter is one of the best dudes on the
roster great guy so I'm talking to you
antsy all sudden nakos hf man tell you
answer you about my you sada rule I got
a shot a rule named after me dog and so
I thought man you're doing something
right when Nate Diaz is like excited
about a change in it you solder rule
right yeah that is a that is a very good
rule I'm really excited about that
what's the story with Nick he can't
fight is he still have like some sort of
oh so yeah well Nick was our first
fighter that ran into the whereabouts
issues so he got three whereabouts
failures and a rolling 12 months so he's
currently going through that process you
know it's a tough one cuz I don't want
to fight I think he does I think he does
I mean we've you know I've sat down with
him over the last couple months and
talking about trying to resolve this
whereabouts issue I mean the unfortunate
thing there is look the whereabouts
failure sanctions are meant to catch
people that are cheating and trying to
avoid testing and I just think Nick's
lifestyle led to those three kind of
whereabouts not that he was trying to
avoid testing just a link being Nick
we're trying to yeah we're trying to
work through that he you know he put he
trusted certain individuals to do his
whereabouts for him I think is what
happened over time and those individuals
would come in and out of his life and of
course kind of unbeknownst to him that
he was missing a lot of these things
nevertheless you know that again there's
strict liability here and it's currently
under sanction but we're hoping to
resolved that pretty quick